how about Tariq my boy Tarkas am i I see
him this weekend had a blast you insane
into that yeah but he goes something
about he goes I just you know I just get
worried I go why he goes all the good
ones in my life go I don't want you to
die I was like hey bro I'm not gonna
[ __ ] die
y'all older I mean goes through people's
head yeah well hold on now if you're a
kid it make would be weird but you are
you're not young I'm 52 I thought about
wife when you pass you kidding me excuse
me like what am I gonna die from I just
had my checkup and the doctor was like
the worst ride since I've ever seen my
36 years on this planet yeah you has got
shingles on your forehead have some
shingles okay okay who knows what's
gonna get you know it seems like shits
up popping up like it stresses over my
skin alright as you get older [ __ ] up
the doctor went holy [ __ ] when he saw me
with your shirt off with you know he
just went yeah you beautiful man no I
was like he goes you're a beautiful man
he goes no says he goes you're always in
here nurses running as in hunting in
Sonoma how was it and killing innocent
bird III got some birds you do with the
dog the dog which is a German Shorthair
runs around and when it sees a dog a
pheasant roosting it points now you know
pheasants my favorite meat of all time
okay so I'm already dying of hunger and
and then the dog you go go and the dog
flushes it the dog goes after it
sometimes I'll catch it as a duck hunt
sometimes the pheasants a little slow
the dog catch them at one point the
pheasant tried to fly out and the dog
grabbed it and held it in his mouth play
him they have a soft mouth and so it
didn't try to kill it and I let it go
and then the bird flew again didn't shot
it in the face up close well I had to
yeah it's not yeah I had to take it out
yeah now now I'm surprised at how
quickly how many times tarik myself and
Joseph miss a bird ouch I would not yeah
where we get shot guns shot guts like
duck duck I had a small shotgun got a
bruise on my on my little army part me
oh yeah it hurts it starts to hurt when
you're when you're a bit of a [ __ ] like
myself but like you run with that duck
and then did you guys eat spasm so you
gotta say it ride a duck but it's a fast
man than that look at that poor thing
what bothers me is your laziness with
the English language just how poor of
that poor little thing yeah
does it tough to scheme see him in the
clear skies and the huge shotgun you
[ __ ] yeah and by the way Huff there's
nothing's it's not out of the year it's
not a real sport no they've been plus
they specialize in helping the field so
they breathe pheasant of course and they
stock the field like shooting an edition
of building they're basically I only do
it because it's so tasty
did you guys eat it like I will say this
about hunting I know you think I'm a
[ __ ] you like I don't like cats right
nope too late look at the picture do you
like after you did it maybe you know I
don't really enjoy killing them now
while you're doing it you like a look at
this Bros shotgun kill another one [ __ ]
these things yeah and now you're gonna
get some [ __ ] you're going to take
some heat online you're like you know
what I actually didn't enjoy any of it
well I don't like the action slaying of
the deer but I like the meat so much
then I will do it and I'll do it
good so whenever I have an opportunity
yeah you do it good yeah I do it good
and I'm rather good shot because I'm
terrified of wounding the animals so I
want to put it out right away I'm not a
hunter dude no but we should do our
mediator together and yeah they still
trying to do that yeah we should really
do have to eat I don't feel like you
know and then yeah like work out you
have to do that yeah it's awful man hawk
that's good no way to get rich shakes
and [ __ ] ah so there's a guy who'd these
powerlifter guys at a gym where they
build monsters and they would like to
seduce some of the strongest men in the
world
yeah you know what the number one food
they make them do is steroids yes for
sure sir yeah
I'm sorry we're huh yeah look but also
to gain weight like makes you a monster
they drink a shitload of milk oh well so
many calories and you know what's a
what's in milk sugar sure [ __ ] and fat a
shitload of sugar and fat calories is
so-so but I feel like so you just do a
lot of protein shakes with a lot of milk
and stuff
oh don't worry well my nephew who was
eating he was at 265 pounds he's now at
215 but when he's playing football that
was same [ __ ] just he'd be big then [ __ ]
ah the Mansi dal ward you they always
make you these and they tell you which
guys had to drink the shakes and then
have a whole shake area just for this
metrics and it was this [ __ ] the
swear man the shake was like the size of
a large big gulp and it was thick and
you'd have to put it all everything in
there and down that oh dude oh man you
have drink I don't know three four of
them a day
really it's not good no it's not good
it's not good all happy for any one guy
but also it's just like what warbled
it's not good you get stronger and you
just no not really
do you think then I remembered I've been
the nutritionist and I was like god
there's sugar in these shakes and like
you're giving us all this these bars
there's a ton of sugar and she goes
don't don't worry about that honey you
guys work out so much you're gonna burn
it off like I'm looking around man
somebody's guys are fat like I don't
feel great either I tell ya it's not
good I don't feel well you know I've
tried I've tried very intermittently to
be like I'm gonna gain weight and then I
feel like just eat this and I talked to
body buzzing I can't do it I just your
body touch my body type is just like hey
like I'm good man I can go a long time
without food I like you know what I
enjoy intermittent fasting
yeah me too everybody everybody I've
talked to who's like and read about like
the real nutritionists and doctors were
on the cutting edge all of them say that
intermittent fasting people disagree
with it but I got to be honest the most
successful people I know interment fast
yeah okay like we don't have a boss
right that was always my thing I don't
want a boss no I'm kind of your boss I
wanted you it's nice on your boss I
don't know that you're fired what you're
rehired
yeah that works dude yep you're back man
that got me so insecure in fire see what
the fire on your back
cat get out it yeah your back dude you
have a lot of power don't do that to me
again because it will see you're getting
a little flushes all right
I don't want rice and you're fired oh
and your back ah [ __ ] Derek you rack
your egg it's not funny man I am sorry
cuz I need I need I need this money I
know I have bills and you're fired
what about my skin I know let that send
you back your
I can't deal with this [ __ ] emotional
rollercoaster sometimes I need a flex on
you guys everyone it's a little too
comfortable in there
see flies those donuts are soggy cat
you're fired and you're back cuz they
weren't we see how everyone's like yeah
you keep us on John I walk in your life
ever had my acting teacher hit me or
that one time he goes he goes this is
terrible what you're doing I was like in
front of 80 people and all people like
who are my peers well I'm and who were
successful actors I was really nervous
and he goes what is this what is what
are you doing what are you doing like
are you doing this a show for us or you
can actually look at the person in front
of you and I was like hmm and I was you
know you're trying to make it in acting
you go I maybe I suck at acting I'm only
32 33 and I suck and maybe this isn't
for me right and go I don't know what I
mean what would it what is this like can
we do acting or how did you get in this
class this is what I get
and then in coop you want to do this
again or you want to sit down I'll be
like I'll do it again and then I I
[ __ ] do really well and he goes you
know what happens when I when I get you
off your PIN you leave that you start to
act there yellows to comfy oh yeah I was
like I'd like you to be off your pins
most of the football don't like you
comfortable coaches do all the time too
you do all the time you go like you're
so incite kind of go through the motions
I'm like that you'd show up
that Tuesday and there'd be a depth
chart and you'd be second string like
what the [ __ ] but they'd only do it for
like two days
oh and then they'd bring you back like
you you've played well enough we're
gonna make you starter now we're really
they didn't have you start the whole
time but yeah it's good
jeffrey tambor in class in front of
everybody I guess I hadn't done a scene
in a little while and well here's the
thing about life when you do well in
class or you gotta get a job you put you
relax a little bit you relax it maybe
I've made it maybe I'm maybe I'm just a
little more advanced I'll let these
other people get a shot class goes
looking around you guys hey Brian you
are you done being the mayor I'm just
curious
are you dumb being the mayor saying hi
to everybody and being the most popular
kid in class because we're we're doing
acting so when when you're ready to do
some more scenes we appreciate it
oh are you gonna be the mayor in front
of everybody I'm a grown man
but then this era said there's
people like Michael Jordan or some of
these ultra winners I'm sure maybe Brad
Pitt you never take they get a little
success and then as soon as you open the
door a little it's game it's because
he's a habit you're never gonna get it
back it's a habit as far as like you
open a door they're gonna take a mile
she just had convinced herself but but
Rogan and I we used to be the worst
lawyer you know we used to have
arguments and he was this way with other
people but he and I a couple times got
in a couple arguments where he'll talk
to us well now because I don't do that
but his girlfriend was like holy [ __ ]
with no [ __ ]
it began shouting at each other at a
dinner table because we were like 20 31
and now we were talking about how when
we have an appointed you I don't get
attached to it we take that argument we
take the idea we put it on the table and
then we kind of like applying it to it
well just let's ask some questions and
Ezer older remember where we in Oklahoma
me and Janice came to blow oh yeah yeah
about about the how hard it is to be a
mom Oh John when the I was like I was
like you like that no you were doing J
like that you know and you were getting
in his face and I think but like we were
kids though it was very strange I
apologized oh you were such a you said
you both are big but you're you know you
are mangu sing the old neck I was so
upset your neck had a bent I was so
upset your neck had an extra muscle in
the back well he kept saying he kept
saying Bobby nabina dad's not yeah and
you were you were craning over and your
odd nostrils were flaring and you were
getting in his face you know what he
tricky triggered things in me that
brought up when we were kids when we get
an argument or whatever it is yes psycho
when I was like what the [ __ ] I was
getting facing what the [ __ ] are you
talking about I'm your brother Romero's
like you his face and he's really just
like it triggered our childhood yes boy
kids died that's dark